we're following breaking news in Hong
Kong where police say a protester was
shot by an officer during violent
demonstrations coinciding with China's
anniversary celebrations police used
tear gas and water cannons to disperse
the crowds in the city's central
business business district overnight
now today marks 70 years since the
founding of the People's Republic of
China
Raymie innocencio is in Hong Kong with
more on this story and I guess rate me
the question is why the escalation in
violence at this time right good morning
Gail while Beijing while mainland China
celebrated with a massive parade here in
Hong Kong the people celebrated with a
mass protest and just looking at what's
been happening here with the violence
this all happened right here and the
anger just got louder broken glass and
fires turned the streets of Hong Kong
into a battleground
police quickly swooped in to subdue
crowds of black-clad protesters first
using tear gas and water cannon and then
by firing warning shots video posted
online appears to show a police officer
shooting a demonstrator at close range
according to reports the man is in
critical condition hours earlier China's
military might was on full display in
Beijing as the country celebrated 70
years of communist rule who are people
speaking to a hand-picked crowd of
thousands President Xi said China must
adhere to the principle of peaceful
reunification and one country two
systems' but today was anything but
peaceful a culmination of the violence
the city has endured since June when
anger over a controversial extradition
bill sparked Hong Kong summer of
discontent pro-democracy activist Joshua
Wong how does this realistically end I
hope this will end with free election
that's our dream and our role and
responsibility is to turn our dream from
impossible to be possible but it was
more of a nightmare really here on the
streets of Hong Kong today at times it
felt like a warzone with sirens going
off people screaming and just smoke
filling the air meantime Chinese
President Xi Jinping in Beijing said he
wants long-term stability for Hong Kong
but definitely looking around today Tony
it was anything but maybe you know sin
SIA for us on the ground again in Hong
Kong ramie thank you very much